Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér. Dr. Papers.
Today I would like show you one
of my favorites - a work that I
am really excited about. Now I
know, I know, you are saying,
Doc, you are always excited for these
papers, and yes, but today, extra excited.
Because today we are going to talk
about how AI will supercharge school
and teaching. Most schools schools have tens,
or in Africa, unfortunately even hundreds of
students for each teacher, and this makes
it very difficult to do this job well.
An ideal teacher would know all the answers
would have infinite patience, and an infinite
amount of time for every student, and perhaps
would also be affordable for the students’
families. But that is ridiculous, of course, such
a teacher has never existed before, until now.
This is Khanmigo from Khan Academy. Khan
academy is an online set of a tools and lectures
that help children study, and now it has been
supercharged by ChatGPT. Let’s marvel together
at how this incredibly knowledgeable chatbot
can supercharge studying for children today.
This is how it helps learning mathematics.
Hoo boy, so let’s just ask it to tell the
answers and we are done! Well, look.
Oh yes, it knows all the answers,
but it would rather help us find out ourselves.
Loving it. Look at how well it slowly guides
the student towards the right solution. And
if we don’t get even the first step right,
it does not get disappointed, it does not run out
of patience. It will be there to help us. Always.
Now hold on to your papers, because this is
my favorite, and I am sure it will be yours
too in a moment. Yes, it also answers the
ultimate question that every student on the
planet has ever asked. And that is “Why
do I need to learn this?” Now, clearly,
every single Young Scholar has this question
in mind, but asking the teacher about it is
not always a good idea. But with an AI? Just
ask as much as you want! It’s not going to
get frustrated, and it has the knowledge
of the entire internet at its disposal.
What does that mean? It means that it can not
only explain what we are studying these for,
but you can even name your favorite activity, for
instance, soccer, and it will tell you exactly
why mathematics could be useful for that.
Predicting player movements, data analytics,
and so on. This is fantastic, and I am 99% sure
it can do it for even more granular things,
not just mathematics in general. You will be able
to know exactly what a particular mathematical
technique you are studying is good for. How it
can enrich your life. Now clearly, this is a
completely different level of teaching. I can only
wish I had a teacher like that. Wow. Imagine how
excited the next generation of Young Scholars
will be with to study with tools like this!
So, what else can it do? Well, it also
quizzes you. And if you don’t know the
answer, it doesn’t just plainly tell you the
answer, but it wants you to find out. First,
you can even ask for a hint. These logs are
available for the teacher who can look up
what the typical mistakes were and discuss
those during the next class. Or even ask
ChatGPT to do it in 10 seconds for all
the students. How incredible is that?
Get this, it can also debate you. If you
wish to start a debate about a sensitive
topic and maybe not reveal some early thoughts
you have that are not fleshed out yet,
you can test it against the AI. It
will not judge you and even help you
refine your arguments or provide
counterarguments to you. So good.
It can also read all the materials
about important historical figures,
and that means that we can even make a
history class come alive by talking to George
Washington. Or even to a god, Zeus himself.
Ah mortal! I love it. This is incredible.
Now, here is the often cited topic, cheating with
writing essays. And here, it really doesn’t go the
way the news keeps presenting to you over and over
again. The AI does not write the essays for the
children. The AI writes with the children, giving
them a really enjoyable experience. Look. We can
choose what kind of story we wish to write. Then,
we get a workflow where we write one paragraph,
then the AI adds one paragraph, and so
on. At the end, you can hand in the logs
and show the work you did together and, for
instance, you can get credit for your part.
I have a daughter, a little Fellow Scholar who
is just about to start school and I cannot tell
you how excited I am to be able to study with
her and use tools like this to enhance her
experience. The next generation of Scholars
is going to be so much smarter. Loving it.
And I just kept looking and
looking at for instance,
the vocabulary building story mode feature
too. And I have to say I don’t see any
cheating. What I see is learning. An amazing
learning experience for the next generation,
and as things improve, likely for us too. An all
this is possible through the power of AI research,
and of course, through the power of
the papers. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!